From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Neil Drumming, sitting in for Ira Glass. Every so often, I'll be talking to another black person, usually someone with an accent. And they'll stop mid-conversation and ask me where my family's from or if I'm from the islands. And I'll say something like, "I'm not sure. I think I'm West Indian on my dad's side." I've said this 100 times without any actual proof. I don't know where I got it from, and there's no evidence that I can find. I asked my dad recently, and he wasn't sure. He said, maybe. Going back generations, someone stopped at some island between Africa and South Carolina.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是尼尔·德拉明，替艾拉·格拉斯主持节目。每隔一段时间，我就会和另一位黑人交谈，通常是那种带有口音的人。他们会在谈话中途停下来，问我家里是哪儿人，或者我是不是来自岛屿。我会说：“我不确定。我想我父亲那边是西印度群岛人。”我这样说过一百次，却没有任何实际证据。我不知道我是从哪听来的，也找不到任何证据。我最近问了我父亲，他也不确定。他说，也许吧。往上追溯几代，某个人在非洲和南卡罗来纳州之间的某个岛屿上停了下来。
My cousin Yvonne, though, her dad was definitely born in Panama. A few years back, she invited me to come stand on the road with her and watch the big party Caribbean people throw here in New York every year, the West Indian Day parade-- technically, the West Indian American Day parade. I still remember how excited she got when a group of Panamanians came marching down Eastern Parkway.
不过我的表亲伊冯，她父亲确实出生在巴拿马。几年前，她邀请我陪她一起站在路边，观看加勒比海人在纽约每年举办的大型派对——西印度群岛日游行，也就是正式名称中的“西印度裔美国人日游行”。我还记得当一群巴拿马人列队走过东公园大道时，她有多兴奋。
My cousin is tall, over six feet, and loud. And she really made a show of jumping and shouting and waving her flag. I envied her in that moment. This is uncomfortable for me to say, but I've sometimes felt a sense of vagueness just being black in America.
我的表亲身材高大，六英尺多，嗓门很大。她确实在大跳、大喊、挥舞旗帜，非常引人注目。那一刻我真羡慕她。说出来虽然让我感到不自在，但我有时作为一个在美的黑人，确实感到一种模糊感。
That's the thing about the West Indian Day parade. There's all these black people who seem to know exactly, specifically, where they're from. And on this one day, they tell everyone. Like, this guy, for example. It's not just where he's from, but it's how he says it.
这就是西印度群岛日游行的特点。这里有这么多黑人，他们似乎非常清楚、具体地知道自己来自哪里。而在这一天，他们会告诉所有人。比如这个人。不仅仅是他来自哪里，还有他说话的方式。
Where are you from?
你来自哪里？
Jamaica.
牙买加。
You live in this neighborhood?
你住在这个街区吗？
No, I'm not living in this neighborhood. I'm living in the Bronx.
不，我不住在这一片。我住在布朗克斯。
OK, so you came all the way down here?
好吧，所以你大老远赶到这里？
Yes, mon...
是的，伙计……
He and his friend came down from the Bronx and had been partying nearby. I ran into them on Eastern Parkway early that morning. The parade hadn't even started yet, but they were already repping their country.
他和他的朋友从布朗克斯赶来，已经在附近参加派对。那天清晨我还在东公园大道上遇到了他们。游行甚至还没开始，但他们已经在为自己的国家代言了。
Jamaicans control-- control the Parkway.
牙买加人控制着……控制着这条大道。
And go on like saying, Jamaican our own things. But we have the best artists, we have the best food, we have the best culture.
我们继续说，牙买加人有我们自己的东西。我们有最棒的艺术家，最棒的食物，最棒的文化。
And we have the best [INAUDIBLE], too.
我们也有最棒的（听不清），也是。
We have to say no more.
我们无需多言。
These guys, they don't even talk like this all the time.
这些家伙，他们平时说话甚至都不是这样的。
So later on, around 10 o'clock, the parade will actually start. That's the big, big thing. You'll see a lot more people flooding the streets.
所以晚些时候，大约10点钟，游行就会真正开始。那才是重头戏。你会看到更多的人涌向街头。
A few years ago, I moved just a few blocks from the parade route on Eastern Parkway, the broad tree-lined corridor that passes through the neighborhood of Crown Heights. The parade is actually part of a week-long celebration in Brooklyn called the Labor Day Carnival, which is itself just the New York version of Carnival, which is celebrated all over the Caribbean and the world.
几年前，我搬到了离东公园大道游行路线仅几个街区的地方，那是一条宽阔的林荫大道，穿过皇冠高地街区。这场游行实际上是布鲁克林为期一周的庆祝活动的一部分，被称为劳动节嘉年华，这本身只是纽约版的狂欢节，而狂欢节在整个加勒比地区和世界各地都在庆祝。
Most days, Crown Heights feels a lot like other neighborhoods I've lived in-- a corner bodega here, a liquor store there, gentrification creeping in. But one weekend every year, I wake up to reggae, and soca, and feathers, and floats, and people waving flags from all over. There's barely anywhere to stand. There's guys on stilts, and there are police everywhere. It feels like the neighborhood's been completely transformed.
大多数日子里，皇冠高地给人的感觉和我住过的其他街区很像——拐角处有个杂货店，那边有个酒铺，中产阶级化正在蔓延。但每年有一个周末，我会在雷鬼音乐、索卡音乐、羽毛、花车以及人们挥舞着来自各国的旗帜声中醒来。几乎没有落脚的地方。有踩高跷的人，到处都是警察。感觉整个街区都彻底改头换面了。
But of course, that's not what's actually happening. It's more like the neighborhood is turning inside out, letting you see what's at its core. So many of the people who make their homes in Crown Heights also carry pieces of another homeland with them-- the Bahamas, Grenada, Jamaica, Barbados, St. Lucia, Trinidad. Every year, anywhere between 1 and 2 million people show up. It's pretty thrilling just to stand on the sidelines and watch it all pass by you, you know, like a parade.
当然，这并不是真正发生的情况。更像是这个街区由内而外地翻转过来，让你看到它的核心。许多在皇冠高地安家的人，同时也随身携带了另一片故土的碎片——巴哈马、格林纳达、牙买加、巴巴多斯、圣卢西亚、特立尼达。每年，大约有100万到200万人到场。站在场边看着这一切从你身边经过，感觉非常震撼，你知道，就像一场游行。
But I wanted to live inside it more, to understand as best I can how my cousin felt that day, to know what it means to have a flag to wave. So that's what we're doing this hour. A bunch of us went out that weekend, dove in headfirst. Some of us even got pretty wet. Stay with us.
但我更想深入其中，尽可能去理解我的表亲那天的感受，去了解挥舞一面旗帜意味着什么。所以这就是我们这一小时要做的。我们这群人那天走了出去，一头扎了进去。我们中的一些人甚至全身湿透了。请留下来。
The typical image New Yorkers have of the West Indian Day parade is of thousands of people dancing down Eastern Parkway in elaborate costumes that are as colorful as they are skimpy-- feathered headdresses, winged backpacks, tiaras, and jeweled bikinis. I learned that this is called playing mas. The mas is short for masquerade.
纽约人对西印度群岛日游行的典型印象是，成千上万的人在东公园大道上跳舞，身着华丽的服装，既色彩斑斓又相当暴露——羽毛头饰、带翼的背包、皇冠和缀满珠宝的比基尼。我了解到这被称为“玩假面”（playing mas）。“Mas”是假面舞会（masquerade）的缩写。
My co-producer Jessica and I went out really early on Labor Day and met up with some masqueraders who were dressed in costumes that they had chosen from a selection of different movie themes, like The Little Mermaid, Coming to America, and Showgirls. Just to say, the outfits were only marginally related to the films. It was more about color palette than anything. One woman wore a plume of black and yellow feathers, evoking Quentin Tarantino's most famous heroine.
我和我的联合制片人杰西卡在劳动节那天很早就出发了，见了一些参与假面游行的人，他们穿着从不同电影主题中挑选的服装，比如《小美人鱼》、《来到美国》和《艳舞女郎》。必须得说，这些装扮与电影的关联度微乎其微。更多的是关于配色，而不是其他。一位女士戴着黑黄相间的羽毛，让人联想到昆汀·塔伦蒂诺最著名的女主角。
So explain your costume. Which costume is this?
解释一下你的服装。这是哪种服装？
So this is Kill Bill. I regret these big feathers. I don't know where I'm going with this. But this is Kill Bill and--
这是《杀死比尔》。我后悔选了这些大羽毛了。我不知道我在搞什么。但这就是《杀死比尔》和……
Why do you regret them?
你为什么后悔？
Because they're-- do you-- girl, I'm going to need you put on a costume and try to walk down the Parkway with big feathers on it. It was a bad mistake. Feathers coming out of this, some stones came off.
因为它们太……你……姑娘，我需要你穿上一套这种服装，戴着大羽毛在大道上走走看。那是个严重的错误。羽毛掉出来了，一些宝石也掉了。
What's the experience of putting on an outfit like this and coming out--
穿上这样的装束走出来是一种什么样的体验……
It's hell. It took me two hours, and a lot of people's breaking down already. We didn't even hit the Parkway. Just know if you're going to do it, just carry a lot of-- not a lot, but carry some Krazy Glue with you. And you're going to be putting yourself together once you get out here.
简直是地狱。我花了两个小时，很多人已经崩溃了。我们甚至还没走到大道上。只要记住，如果你要参加，带上大量的——不用太多，但带上一些强力胶。一旦你到了这里，你就会不停地修补自己。
What made you decide on Kill Bill?
是什么让你决定选《杀死比尔》？
To be honest with you, I'm chubby. So Kill Bill had a monokini, and I liked it, so I went with that. And me and a two-piece, we ain't friends right now. And we ain't hit the gym. So Kill Bill it was.
老实说，我有点胖。所以《杀死比尔》有一件连体比基尼，我很喜欢，所以就选了这个。而我和两件套比基尼现在合不来。我们也没去健身房。所以就选《杀死比尔》了。
For many people, playing mas starts even earlier than the parade, at the parade before the parade. It's called J'ouvert, and it's a celebration with deep, deep roots in the Caribbean. J'ouvert's mythology is populated with outlandish characters, like the menacing Midnight Robber with his wide-brimmed hat, the insanely voluptuous Dame Lorraine, and the many devils.
对许多人来说，玩假面比游行本身开始得更早，是在游行前的游行。它被称为“黎明节”（J'ouvert），是一个在加勒比地区有着极其深厚根源的庆祝活动。黎明节的神话中充满了奇异的角色，比如戴着宽边帽、充满威胁感的“午夜强盗”，极度丰满的“洛林夫人”，以及众多的恶魔。
Writer Imani Brown grew up with J'ouvert, but she didn't actually start going until she got to Brooklyn. Her story starts over 2,000 miles away.
作家伊曼妮·布朗从小就参加黎明节，但直到她来到布鲁克林，她才真正开始参与其中。她的故事始于2000多英里之外。
In Trinidad, Carnival is so big that you study it in school. The year I turned 10, we were given an assignment to pick one of the traditional Carnival mas characters we just learned about, create a costume, and put on a performance in front of the rest of the school.
在特立尼达，狂欢节规模大到你在学校都要学习它。我10岁那年，老师布置了一项任务：挑选一个我们刚学过的传统狂欢节假面角色，制作一套服装，并在全校师生面前表演。
Picking my character was a struggle. But in the end, I settled on the jab molassie, sometimes called the Blue Devil in Trinidad. I picked it mostly because I knew the costume would be one of the easiest to make, and time was running out. I cut holes into an old pair of shorts and a thin T-shirt. I fashioned horns from paper towel rolls and looped strips of paper into a chain that I could wrap around my body. A pitchfork I fabricated from tree branches from my backyard completed the look.
挑选我的角色是一场挣扎。但最终，我选定了“糖蜜恶魔”（jab molassie），在特立尼达有时被称为“蓝恶魔”。我选它主要是因为我知道服装是最容易制作的，而且时间不多了。我把一条旧短裤和一件薄T恤剪了洞。我用纸巾卷做了角，把纸条编成链子缠在身上。我用后院的树枝做了一把干草叉，完成了整个造型。
On the day of the performance, I changed into my costume in the classroom, smeared myself all over with blue paint, and then headed towards the auditorium. I was the kind of child who avoided attention, and everything in me was fighting the idea of being onstage. When I stepped out alone in front of the whole school, my heart was racing.
演出那天，我在教室里换上服装，全身涂满蓝色颜料，然后向礼堂走去。我是那种回避注视的孩子，内心深处极度排斥在台上表演的想法。当我独自站在全校师生面前时，我的心跳在加速。
My teacher told us that the jab molassie was a demon that terrorizes, a creature barely kept on its leash. So on the stage that day, I might have crouched, or jumped, or hissed, or bared my teeth at the crowd-- I'm not sure. I just remember my anxiety wasn't painful anymore. It was exhilarating. I felt wicked, and nasty, and playful, and tricky. So completely out of character and still so utterly myself. Deeply inside my body and yet somehow floating above it. When it's good, that's what it feels like to play mas.
老师告诉我们，糖蜜恶魔是一个四处制造恐怖的恶魔，是一个难以被控制的生物。所以那天在台上，我可能蹲下、跳跃、嘶嘶作响，或者向人群龇牙咧嘴——我不确定。我只记得我的焦虑不再痛苦了。它令人振奋。我感到邪恶、粗鲁、顽皮且狡猾。完全不像平时的我，却又如此彻底地做回了自己。深深沉浸在身体里，却又仿佛漂浮在它之上。当感觉良好时，玩假面就是这种体验。
For a long time, mas didn't really feel like mine. I grew up in Trinidad, but my father and mother are from Jamaica and Guyana respectively. Carnival in those places simply does not compare to the space the festival takes up in Trinidad, where Carnival is king and its influence swirls year round.
很长一段时间里，假面感觉并不属于我。我在特立尼达长大，但我父母分别来自牙买加和圭亚那。那些地方的狂欢节根本无法与特立尼达相比，在特立尼达，狂欢节是国王，它的影响一年四季都在盘旋。
Everyone, my mother would say, laughing and shaking her head, everyone from the biggest partier to the most religious church mouse is out on the road come Monday. My family didn't go to church regularly, but there was no way my parents were going to let me participate in Carnival proper as a teenager. That was for grown people.
我母亲总是笑着摇头说，每个人，从最爱聚会的人到最虔诚的信徒，周一都会出现在街上。我家平时不去教堂，但我父母绝不会让我作为一个青少年参加正式的狂欢节。那是大人的事。
When I left Trinidad for college in the States, the loneliness took me by surprise. I was 18, and homesickness was a physical and nearly constant ache. It was then that I played J'ouvert for the first time at Brooklyn's Labor Day parade. There, I finally felt at home again. And in the year since, the parade has become a spiritual practice.
当我离开特立尼达去美国读大学时，孤独感让我措手不及。我当时18岁，思乡之情是一种持续不断的生理痛楚。就在那时，我在布鲁克林的劳动节游行上第一次参加了黎明节。在那里，我终于再次感到了家的感觉。从那以后，这场游行成了一种精神修行。
J'ouvert always begins in the dark. This year, climbing up and out of the subway at Grand Army Plaza, the sky isn't quite pitch black, but it's close. Against the glare of police floodlights, I can just make out a stream of people trickling down the road in clumps. My friends and I join the stream, moving towards the NYPD metal barriers that narrow into a checkpoint. We are patted down and our bags opened.
黎明节总是在黑暗中开始。今年，当我爬出大军团广场的地铁站时，天空还不完全是漆黑一片，但也很接近了。在警察探照灯的强光下，我能辨认出人群正零星地涌向街道。我和朋友们加入这股洪流，走向缩窄成检查站的纽约警局金属护栏。我们接受了搜身，包也被打开了。
How're you doing, ma'am? Can you just open that up and just show me all what you got in there?
你好吗，女士？能打开那个看看里面有什么吗？
J'ouvert is derived from the French Creole word for daybreak. And traditionally, Brooklyn starts at around 4:00 AM, ending not too long after the sun rises. But this year, the rising sun is what marks the beginning of the parade. At 6:00 AM, the parade is starting much later than usual. The reason given is that it will help curb the violence that many have come to associate with the event.
黎明节源自法语克里奥尔语中“破晓”的意思。传统上，布鲁克林是在凌晨4点左右开始，直到日出后不久结束。但今年，日出标志着游行的开始。早上6点，游行比平时开始得晚得多。给出的理由是这将有助于遏制许多人已将其与此活动联系在一起的暴力事件。
In 2015, a young lawyer in Governor Andrew Cuomo's administration, Carey Gabay, was hit and killed by a stray bullet along the route. The next year, it was reported that four people were shot at the parade, two of whom died. Here's what's rarely mentioned in those news reports. The violence that black people experience in these long neglected neighborhoods is year round. It doesn't end when the cameras leave the parade. And in some cases, the incidents that the media have connected to the parade happen away from the parade's actual route.
2015年，安德鲁·科莫政府的一名年轻律师凯里·盖贝在路线上被流弹击中身亡。次年，有报道称四人在游行中被枪杀，其中两人死亡。新闻报道中很少提及这一点：黑人在这些长期被忽视的社区所经历的暴力是全年无休的。它不会在摄像机离开游行路线后就停止。在某些情况下，媒体与游行挂钩的事件实际上发生在游行路线之外。
The news coverage J'ouvert typically receives is frustrating, but not surprising. No matter what part of the globe you're from, you know that this is part of what it means to be black. The things you do to secure joy for yourself in a world that would rather see you dead become the way the world then rationalizes your suffering.
黎明节通常收到的新闻报道令人沮丧，但并不令人惊讶。无论你来自地球的哪个角落，你都知道这是身为黑人意味着的一部分。你在一个宁愿看到你死去的世界中为自己获取快乐所做的事情，最终成为了世界合理化你所受苦难的方式。
For the media, for everyone outside of our community, the story of the parade is the story of the violence. This is why it feels impossible to smile back when the officer checking our bags grins as if we're sharing an inside joke and comments, "Just need to make sure you don't have a gun," before letting us through.
对于媒体，对于我们社区之外的每一个人来说，游行的故事就是暴力的故事。这就是为什么当检查我们包的警察咧嘴一笑，仿佛在分享一个内部笑话并评论道：“只是需要确保你们没有枪”，然后才放我们通过时，我们很难回以微笑。
Once we're past the checkpoint, the crowd thickens. It's clear that for some people, the morning is just beginning, and that for others, a long night of partying is simply stretching itself a little bit longer. Everyone is drifting, tripping down the street in no real hurry.
一旦通过检查站，人群就变密集了。很明显，对一些人来说，清晨才刚刚开始；而对另一些人来说，漫长的派对之夜只是又延续了一点。每个人都在飘荡，摇摇晃晃地走在街上，并不着急。
No one is wearing anything they wouldn't mind sacrificing to the J'ouvert gods-- old tanks and short shorts, ratty T-shirts, and strappy dresses that ride up the thigh. Flags are everywhere, tied around waists, worn as capes. The red, green, and gold of Grenada's flag in particular can be seen near and far.
没人穿什么舍不得为黎明节之神献祭的衣服——旧背心和短裤、破旧的T恤，以及向上卷起的细带连衣裙。旗帜到处都是，绑在腰间，披在身上。格林纳达国旗的红、绿、金三色尤其随处可见。
The closer we get to the front of the route, the more clearly we can hear the sound of whistles and conchs up the road. The tinny sound of somebody beating out a rhythm on a small metal pan is joined briefly by the heavy beat of a cowbell. Both are swallowed up by the sound of the steel pan band warming up.
我们离游行队伍的前方越近，听到的哨子声和海螺号声就越清晰。有人在小金属锅上敲击节奏的叮当声，短暂地加入了牛铃沉重的节奏。两者都被钢鼓乐队热身的声音吞没了。
And the devils are out. The Grenadian jab jabs are covered from head to toe in slick, black oil. The whites of their eyes and teeth seem to jump out of their skin. Locks and wigs and braids are wrapped up tightly in plastic bags. Sacrificing old clothes is one thing, but getting oil and powder out of a new sew-in is quite another.
恶魔们出场了。格林纳达的“贾布贾布”（jab jabs）从头到脚覆盖着湿滑的黑油。他们眼白和牙齿在皮肤上显得格外醒目。脏辫、假发和辫子被塑料袋紧紧包裹着。牺牲旧衣服是一回事，但要把油和粉末从新做的接发里弄出来则是另一回事。
The devils wear hardhats and helmets crowned with black horns. I narrowly avoid getting hit by one of the many shopping carts many of the devils are pushing down the road, most of them full of plastic bags and buckets-- and in some cases, other passed-out devils.
恶魔们戴着安全帽，头盔上戴着黑色的角。我险些被那些恶魔推着的小推车撞到，大多数小推车装满了塑料袋和水桶——在某些情况下，还有其他昏倒的恶魔。
The smell of grease and smoke rose heavier. Two young devils spot my friends and me and loudly proclaim that we're too clean. One of the devils dips his hands into a bucket of oil, and the other beckons us closer. He smiles wide, and it's both a dare and a promise, an invitation and a threat. We shake our heads, but we're all laughing as he walks up to us and starts rubbing us down with the oil anyway. You don't come to J'ouvert if you're not prepared to get dirty.
油烟味愈发浓重。两名年轻的恶魔发现了我和朋友，大声宣布我们太干净了。其中一个恶魔把手伸进油桶，另一个招呼我们靠近。他笑得很灿烂，那既是一个挑战也是一个承诺，一个邀请也是一种威胁。我们摇头，但当他走近我们并开始用油涂抹我们时，我们都笑了。如果不准备好弄脏自己，就别来参加黎明节。
The U-Haul vans pulling along the rhythm section and steel pan bands, who are now in full swing, start inching down the road. A woman climbs on top of the bumper of a van, winding her way slowly in a smooth, rippling motion that extends from her shoulders down to her legs. A man hoists himself up behind her, and she picks up the pace.
拉着节奏部和钢鼓乐队的U-Haul货车正在全力前进。一名女子爬上货车的保险杠，随着平滑的波动动作，从肩膀一直蜿蜒到双腿。一名男子在她身后把她拉起，她加快了节奏。
We flag down a young woman selling Nutcrackers, sweet drinks mixed heavily with rum and vodka, despite reports of a crackdown on the sale of these drinks. She asks if she can take a picture of us that she then posts on her Instagram to promote her business. We all giggle like we've known each other for years as we pose.
我们拦住了一位卖“胡桃夹子”（一种混合了大量朗姆酒和伏特加的甜饮料）的年轻女性，尽管有报道称正在打击此类饮料的销售。她问是否可以给我们拍张照，然后发布在她的Instagram上来推广她的生意。我们拍照时都咯咯笑着，仿佛相识多年。
Trying to mark the moment the parade slides from darkness into daylight is like trying to track the ripening of a mango. It happens slowly and then all at once. Suddenly, I'm squinting into the sun, and everything that felt clear in the night looks and feels strange to me now. This is a part of it, too. Within this space, what is real and what is a hallucination?
试图标记游行从黑暗滑向黎明的时刻，就像试图跟踪芒果的成熟过程一样。它发生得很慢，然后瞬间完成。突然间，我在阳光下眯起眼睛，夜里感觉清晰的一切，现在看来和感觉起来都很陌生。这也是它的一部分。在这个空间里，什么是真实的，什么是幻觉？
Moko jumbies, sure-footed performers on six-foot stilts, drift by like clouds without looking down. Three devils covered in white paint are on the roof of a nearby building, winding and waving a huge Trinidad flag over the crowd, as if claiming territory. How did they get up there? I have no idea. But somehow, in the moment, there's nothing that doesn't make sense.
踩着六英尺高跷的莫科巨人（Moko jumbies）步履稳健地漂过，像云朵一样，从不低头。三个涂着白色颜料的恶魔在附近建筑的屋顶上，在人群上方挥舞着一面巨大的特立尼达国旗，仿佛在宣示领土。他们是怎么上去的？我不知道。但不知何故，在那个时刻，一切都显得合情合理。
J'ouvert began as a way to celebrate surviving the most brutal aspects of slavery. In J'ouvert, you can see out of the eyes of the demons that once drove you with the whip. You can embody the worst thing that ever hurt you and come out the other side invincible. When our people were enslaved, they were driven into burning cane fields to harvest the land. Those that survived came out covered in soot and ash. The horror defies imagination.
黎明节最初是一种庆祝在奴隶制最残酷的方面幸存下来的方式。在黎明节，你可以透过曾经用鞭子驱赶你的恶魔的眼睛看世界。你可以化身为曾经伤害过你的最恶劣的东西，并从另一边完好无损地走出来。当我们的祖先被奴役时，他们被赶进燃烧的甘蔗田收割土地。幸存下来的人出来时全身覆盖着煤烟和灰烬。那种恐怖超乎想象。
But at every turn, we have been taught that we are weak, that we are cowards, that we are less than human. So we play J'ouvert to remember that no one has the power to make monsters of us but ourselves. We play J'ouvert, and in that time, we become more fearsome than anything that could ever terrorize us. In a world that asks us to be quieter, to do less, to accept the worst of everything and to pretend to like it, J'ouvert becomes the altar where we can finally fall to our knees and worship ourselves.
但在每一个转弯处，我们都被教导我们是软弱的，我们是懦夫，我们非人类。所以我们参加黎明节，是为了记住除了我们自己，没有人有权把我们变成怪物。我们参加黎明节，在那段时间里，我们变得比任何可能恐吓我们的东西都更可怕。在一个要求我们安静、少做、接受一切最坏的事情并假装喜欢它的世界里，黎明节成了我们可以最终跪下崇拜我们自己的祭坛。
I am two Nutcrackers in when the brass of the rhythm section really gets going. Something deep and sweet fills me. This year has been harder than most. I haven't had the money for a plane ticket, and it's been over a year since I was in my backyard, pressing my feet into the grass, watching the sunset, feeling the wetness of the air hug my body. There is a person I am when I am home, and I miss her desperately.
当我喝了两杯“胡桃夹子”时，节奏部的铜管乐器真正开始了。某种深刻而甜蜜的东西填满了我的内心。今年比往年更艰难。我没钱买机票，距离我在后院赤脚踩在草地上，看着日落，感受潮湿的空气拥抱我的身体，已经过去一年多了。我在家时是另一个人，我非常想念她。
Now, a current runs through my chest, my belly, my legs. I am not home, but I am home. I'm home. I swing my hips and roll my waist and slow dance, and for a moment, feel the way I did when I was 10, jumping back and forth between fear and exhilaration, getting low to the ground, feeling something like awe and pride start to crack my chest open.
现在，一股电流流过我的胸膛、腹部和双腿。我不在家，但我感觉就在家。我摆动臀部，扭动腰肢，跳着慢舞，那一刻，我感觉自己回到了10岁，在恐惧和兴奋之间跳跃，身体压低，感受到某种像敬畏和自豪的东西开始撕裂我的胸腔。
Imani Brown is a Jamaican writer and poet whose work focuses on race, gender, and Caribbean folklore. She lives in Brooklyn.
伊曼妮·布朗是一位牙买加作家和诗人，作品关注种族、性别和加勒比民间传说。她住在布鲁克林。
Pretty much all summer, if you're walking around certain parts of Brooklyn, you can hear the sound of steel drums late into the night. But you never really see them. I always wonder, where are the steel drums coming from? Because when the parade comes along, it's all flatbed trucks loaded with DJ equipment and booming speakers.
整个夏天，如果你走在布鲁克林的某些地方，你总能听到钢鼓的声音持续到深夜。但你从没真正见过它们。我总是好奇，钢鼓声是从哪儿来的？因为当游行到来时，全是装满了DJ设备和轰鸣扬声器的平板卡车。
What was all that steel drumming I heard? As it turns out, part of Labor Day Carnival is a whole steel drum competition. It's called Panorama. Those mysterious tropical sounds in the night, those are steel jam orchestras practicing, sometimes 100 people all playing together.
我听到的那些钢鼓声是什么？原来，劳动节嘉年华的一部分是一场完整的钢鼓比赛。它被称为“全景”（Panorama）。那些夜晚神秘的热带声音，是钢鼓乐团在练习，有时多达100人一起演奏。
You know, when I say to people, "I practice every night," like, they'll say, well, can you do this? And I'm like, no, I have practice. You practice every night. I'm like, yeah, I say I practice every night every time.
你知道，当我对别人说“我每晚都在练习”时，他们会说，好吧，你能做到这个吗？我说，不，我有练习。你每晚都练习？我说，是的，我每次都说我每晚都在练习。
Even members of our family.
甚至我们的家人也是。
Even members of our family are like, you're going to practice? Yes, we're going to practice. It's what we do.
甚至我们的家人也会说，你要去练习？是的，我们要去练习。这是我们做的事。
That's Angie and her daughter Jona. This is the thing they do together every year, all summer long. And they were really hoping their band would win this year. The competition was basically going to be the last thing they did together as mom and teenage daughter. As soon as it was over, literally hours after it was over, Jona would get on a flight and leave home for her first year in college.
那是安吉和她的女儿乔娜。这是她们每年整个夏天都在一起做的事情。她们真的希望自己的乐队今年能赢。这场比赛基本上将是她们作为母女在一起做的最后一件事。一旦结束，就在结束后的几个小时内，乔娜就会登机，离开家去上大学的第一年。
I don't know anything about steel drums, or pans, as they're called. But we found a reporter, Marlon Bishop, who is also a musician and who loves this instrument. He followed Angie and Jona as they prepared, and one of our producers, Nadia Reiman, went with them to the competition.
我对钢鼓一无所知，或者叫它“锅”（pans）。但我们找到了一位记者马龙·毕晓普，他也是一名音乐家，非常热爱这种乐器。他跟踪安吉和乔娜的准备过程，我们的制片人之一纳迪亚·雷曼也随她们一起参加了比赛。
The band Angie and Jona play in is called Radoes. The name comes from this famous band in Trinidad called Desperadoes. The US branch of it was called Despers, but then there was a rebellion in the ranks and the band split. It was like a divorce. The rebels were like, you want to be Despers? Fine, we'll be Radoes. That was years ago, though, and it's all good now. Well, kind of. They're rivals-- friendly rivals.
安吉和乔娜参加的乐队叫Radoes。名字来源于特立尼达一支著名的乐队，叫Desperadoes。它的美国分部叫Despers，但后来内部发生了叛乱，乐队分裂了。就像离婚一样。叛军说，你们想做Despers？好吧，那我们就做Radoes。那是几年前的事了，现在一切都好了。好吧，某种程度上。她们是竞争对手——友好的竞争对手。
We don't want them to win.
我们不希望她们赢。
Not necessarily we don't want them to win, but we want to win on our own.
不一定是我们不希望她们赢，而是我们想凭自己的实力赢。
No, no, no. We don't want-- I don't want them to win. Not really--
不，不，不。我们不希望……我不希望她们赢。并非真的……
Right, no, it's not that we don't want them to win. It's we want to win.
好吧，不，不是说我们不希望她们赢。而是我们想赢。
Yeah, no, no, no. I'm going to say I don't want--
是的，不，不，不。我要说我不希望……
Really?
真的吗？
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Like, you can want to win all you want.
就像，你想赢就可以想赢。
I'm like, I want to win. Like, I don't want just anyone to win. I want Radoes to win.
我是说，我想赢。我不希望随便哪个人赢。我希望Radoes赢。
Their band Radoes has a reputation for being a vibes band. Maybe not as tight as some other groups, but compensating with spirit. On the stage, they play loud and bold. And for a while, Radoes did win, three years in a row. But then last year, Despers--
她们的乐队Radoes以“氛围乐队”而闻名。可能不像其他团体那样严谨，但以精神取胜。在舞台上，她们演奏得大声且大胆。有一段时间，Radoes确实连续三年赢了。但去年，Despers……
Despers won last year.
Despers去年赢了。
They won last year.
她们去年赢了。
It was very troubling.
那太令人不安了。
It was the most heartbreaking thing ever.
这是有史以来最令人心碎的事情。
Can you talk about that?
你能谈谈那个吗？
I was so sad.
我太难过了。
Why?
为什么？
We worked so hard.
我们工作得那么辛苦。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
I first met Angie and Jona at the big lot where the band practices. It's in an industrial part of Brooklyn next to a bus depot-- you know, less neighbors to complain about the noise.
我第一次见到安吉和乔娜是在乐队练习的大场地。它位于布鲁克林一个工业区，旁边是个公交车库——你知道，邻居少点，没那么多人抱怨噪音。
You're coming a little up, a little up.
你再高一点，再高一点。
Jona is trying to nail down a section in the music that's been giving her trouble.
乔娜正试图攻克音乐中一直困扰她的一个部分。
Ba dum ba dum ba bum ba dum. No, no, no.
Ba dum ba dum ba bum ba dum。不，不，不。
No, you're changing it.
不，你改动它了。
Ba da dum ba dum. You're changing the phrasing. Play it again. Ba da dum ba dum.
Ba da dum ba dum。你改变了措辞。再弹一遍。Ba da dum ba dum。
What's this pan called?
这个锅叫什么？
This is the--
这是……
This is the quadraphonics.
这是四声道音响（quadraphonics）。
I'm sorry, was he asking you?
抱歉，他是在问你吗？
He asked both of us.
他问的是我们俩。
This is a quadra pan.
这是一个四声部钢鼓（quadra pan）。
That's a really hard one, right?
那是一个非常难的，对吧？
It's very hard, yeah. But it's fun. It's really exciting to play.
是的，非常难。但很有趣。演奏起来真的很令人兴奋。
This yard is like their second home. Angie, the mom, left Grenada when she was three years old-- grew up in Queens.
这个院子就像她们的第二个家。妈妈安吉三岁时离开格林纳达——在皇后区长大。
When I told my mother I was going to play pan, she looked at me and she shook her head. And she said, you are the bane of my existence. Just like that. I was like, it's not that deep. I'm going to play some music. But it's male dominated.
当我告诉母亲我要玩钢鼓时，她看着我，摇了摇头。她说，你是我生命中的克星。就这样。我说，没那么严重吧。我只是要演奏一些音乐。但这是男性主导的。
Basically. It's just music.
基本上。这只是音乐。
Yeah, I know.
是的，我知道。
Women didn't really play pan back in the day. They do now, though. Angie played pregnant with Jona. And after Jona was born, as a baby, she'd ride on Angie's back as she practiced. Jona started playing in the band when she was eight years old-- played every year since. She loves it-- so much so that in this last summer before she leaves for college, she's choosing to spend every night right here with her mom, getting ready for the competition.
过去女性并不怎么玩钢鼓。但现在她们玩了。安吉在怀着乔娜时还在演奏。乔娜出生后，她还是个婴儿时，就会骑在安吉的背上练习。乔娜8岁时开始在乐队里演奏——从那以后每年都弹。她热爱它——以至于在去大学前的最后一个夏天，她选择每天晚上都待在这里和妈妈在一起，为比赛做准备。
The way the Panorama competition works, each band plays an eight to 10 minute long, incredibly complicated arrangement of a popular soca song. The arrangements are filled with crazy runs and breakdowns, which, in a kind of Calypso arms race, get more and more virtuosic every year.
全景比赛的运作方式是，每个乐队演奏一段8到10分钟长、编排极其复杂的流行索卡歌曲。编排中充满了疯狂的乐句和变奏，在某种卡里普索式的军备竞赛中，每年都变得越来越精湛。
Everyone will tell you the key to winning this thing, it's having a good arranger, the person who comes up with all the parts. Most bands use local arrangers from Brooklyn, but Radoes hires a ringer from Trinidad, a guy named BJ. Normally they'll bring up BJ for the whole summer to teach the song, but this time, there's a problem. He had trouble getting a visa, so he's been teaching over the phone.
每个人都会告诉你赢下这场比赛的关键是有一个好的编曲人，即负责创作所有乐段的人。大多数乐队使用布鲁克林的本地编曲人，但Radoes从特立尼达雇了一个外援，一个叫BJ的家伙。通常他们会把BJ请来整个夏天教这首歌，但这次出了问题。他签证出了点问题，所以他一直在通过电话教学。
Every night, someone gets their cell phone with a cable, and they connect it to this giant speaker that everyone gathers around. BJ teaches the music by calling out the notes one by one through the phone, which this other guy, called the drill master, then repeats to the rest of the orchestra.
每天晚上，有人拿出一台连着线缆的手机，把它接在大扬声器上，大家围在周围。BJ通过电话逐个叫出音符来教授音乐，另一位被称为“钻研大师”的家伙再向管弦乐队的其他成员重复。
It's C and F, F and G sharp, E and G.
是C和F，F和升G，E和G。
It starts on B and F then?
是从B和F开始吗？
C and F.
C和F。
Yeah, C and F. C.
是的，C和F。C。
F and G sharp.
F和升G。
OK, E and F?
好的，E和F？
C!
C！
C! Cat, cat.
C！猫，猫。
BJ has to teach every note of a 10 minute song this way. And there's not just one part. It's an 100-person orchestra with different sections that play different notes and rhythms. No sheet music involved. This is music learned entirely by ear.
BJ必须通过这种方式教授10分钟歌曲中的每一个音符。而且不仅有一个部分。这是一个由100人组成的管弦乐队，有不同的部分演奏不同的音符和节奏。不涉及乐谱。这是完全靠耳朵学习的音乐。
Another thing here.
这里还有别的东西。
F and G sharp.
F和升G。
Right.
对了。
E and G.
E和G。
I will be telling you.
我会告诉你的。
The yard feels like an extended family barbecue that happens every single night. There's a makeshift bar in the back that serves beer and food. That's where all the good gossip happens. Overall, it's about half players and half people who are just there to hang out-- lots of kids running around, significant others of band members, plus a contingent of old guys smoking weed in the back. People said it feels kind of like being back home in the Caribbean.
这个院子感觉就像每天晚上都有的大家庭烧烤。后面有一个简易的酒吧，提供啤酒和食物。那是所有八卦发生的地方。总的来说，大约有一半是球员，另一半是纯粹来闲逛的人——很多孩子跑来跑去，乐队成员的伴侣，外加一帮在后面抽大麻的老家伙。人们说感觉有点像回到了加勒比海的家。
During breaks, Jona hangs out with her best friend, Z, and some of the other girls her age, on a set of wooden bleachers. I notice at one point they're talking about neighborhoods in Trinidad. And they don't say, my family lives in such and such a place. They say, I live there.
休息期间，乔娜和她最好的朋友Z以及一些同龄的女孩待在木制看台上。我注意到她们有一次在谈论特立尼达的社区。她们不说“我家人住在某某地方”，她们说“我住在那里”。
Where do you live?
你住在哪里？
Arima.
阿里马。
You live in Arima?
你住在阿里马？
No, I live in 'Bago.
不，我住在多巴哥（'Bago）。
I live in-- my dad lives in 'Bago. I'm over there.
我住在——我爸爸住在多巴哥。我就在那边。
You guys all live in Brooklyn.
你们都住在布鲁克林。
Yes.
是的。
But you're talking about Trinidad.
但你们在谈论特立尼达。
Yes.
是的。
You would swear we grew up there, though.
你肯定会发誓说我们是在那里长大的。
You don't really think that we grew up in some of these--
你不觉得我们是在那些地方长大的吧……
Honestly, when we turn on our fake ass accent-- because we wasn't born there, we just turn it on.
老实说，当我们使用那种假的口音时——因为我们不是在那里出生的，我们只是把它打开。
My mom be like, you swear you're Trinadi.
我妈妈会说，你发誓你是特立尼达人。
The high school Jona just graduated from, there weren't a lot of West Indian kids there.
乔娜刚毕业的高中里，没有多少西印度裔的孩子。
I don't talk to my friends about pan and that at all because I don't think there's a good enough way for me to explain it without people thinking I'm crazy. Like, I'm so serious. I mean, I can't explain to them that I'm standing up for hours a night, just playing music and coming home at 3 o'clock and having to wake up the next day. I can't explain all the riff raff that happens. I can't.
我根本不和朋友谈论钢鼓之类的事情，因为我觉得我无法在不让别人认为我疯了的情况下解释清楚。我是认真的。我的意思是，我无法向他们解释我每天晚上站着演奏几个小时，凌晨3点回家，第二天还得醒来。我无法解释发生的所有乱七八糟的事情。我不能。
There are fights.
会有争吵。
Right, as an example. It's a family, and it has arguments. To me, it's like-- I keep on saying it's like the epicenter of forgiveness. Because you can do anything--
对，作为一个例子。这是一个家庭，它有争论。对我来说，就像——我一直在说这就像宽恕的震中。因为你可以做任何事……
You can literally do anything.
你可以真的做任何事。
You can literally do anything, and then you can come back.
你可以真的做任何事，然后你又可以回来。
And then cool off a year and a half or so, and then come back, and people will be like, oh, hi.
然后冷静一年半左右，再回来，人们会说，哦，嗨。
They're alluding to something specific here. One year, one of the Radoes players got into a beef and brought a gun into another pan yard. And someone ended up getting shot. It was a bad time, Angie said. The guy went to jail. But when he got out, he came back to the band, and people said, OK.
她们在这里暗示某种具体的事情。有一年，其中一名Radoes球员卷入了一场纠纷，把枪带到了另一个钢鼓练习场。结果有人被枪击了。那是一段糟糕的时光，安吉说。那家伙进了监狱。但他出来后，又回到了乐队，人们说，好吧。
It's a place of redemption. You belong to us, right, and we belong in the same environment. And we know how to make peace with one another. That's not something you see all the time. That's not something you see all the time.
这是一个救赎的地方。你属于我们，对吧，我们属于同一个环境。而且我们知道如何与彼此和解。这不是你经常能看到的。这不是你经常能看到的。
I come back a few weeks later and BJ, the ringer, the arranger from Trinidad, his visa has finally been sorted out. He's here in person. You can feel the change of energy in the yard. There's way more players, and the music is starting to sound really good.
几周后我又回来了，外援、特立尼达的编曲人BJ的签证终于办好了。他亲自来到了这里。你可以感觉到院子里能量的变化。球员多了很多，音乐听起来也真的很好。
As I'm recording the band, a guy calls me over and tells me, in no uncertain terms, that I am not to share the recordings with any rival bands.
当我录制乐队时，一个家伙叫我过去，毫不含糊地告诉我，我不能把录音分享给任何竞争对手乐队。
Ladies and gentlemen, this is a competition. And therefore, we must have judges. Our judges this evening are--
女士们、先生们，这是一场比赛。因此，我们必须有评委。我们今晚的评委是……
This finally is the night of Panorama, Labor Day weekend. My colleague, Nadia Reiman, was there for that. She's going to take it from here.
这终于到了劳动节周末的全景比赛之夜。我的同事纳迪亚·雷曼也在那里。她接手报道。
The competition takes place in the parking lot of the Brooklyn Museum. The streets are blocked off. There's tons of U-Hauls filled with drums and racks, tons of people setting up pans, rolling them about. It's like being backstage. When I get there an hour before showtime, Angie is dashing from place to place, setting up drums, making sure people have their shirts. The Radoes are all wearing T-shirts that say, "Hookin' Meh" on them. That's the song they're playing. Oh, also, she's getting people rides who are supposed to be here, but aren't.
比赛在布鲁克林博物馆的停车场举行。街道被封锁了。有大量的U-Haul货车装满了鼓和架子，大量的人在架设钢鼓，四处滚动。就像在后台一样。我在表演前一小时到达时，安吉正从一个地方跑到另一个地方，架设鼓，确保人们有他们的衬衫。Radoes的所有人都穿着写着“Hookin' Meh”的T恤。那是她们演奏的歌。哦，对了，她还得帮那些应该到场但还没到的人叫车。
Are you ready now? OK, get up here as soon as you can, because they want you to start hooking up the drums. Tell me the address of the place. I'll send you a car.
你准备好了吗？好的，尽快赶到这里，因为他们想让你开始架鼓。告诉我那个地方的地址。我会送你一辆车。
She sees Jona walking toward us in the distance. She can tell just from her walk. Radoes is going to play second, which is stressing Angie out. You want to play last. That way, the judges remember you. Most of the bands that are going first are pretty set up, starting to run through their songs. But Radoes is still not ready, still not practicing. Despers is. Jona seems not concerned, like at all. Really, she's not. Stop talking about it.
她看到乔娜从远处向我们走来。她一眼就能看出她的走路姿势。Radoes将第二个出场，这让安吉压力很大。你希望最后一个出场。这样，评委们会记住你。大多数第一组上场的乐队准备得相当充分，开始排练她们的歌曲了。但Radoes还没准备好，还没排练。Despers在练习。乔娜似乎一点也不担心，真的，她一点也不担心。别再谈论它了。
Despers USA, the one who won last year, that's them right now.
Despers USA，去年赢了的那支，现在轮到她们了。
That's like your rival?
那是你的竞争对手？
Ah, they just won last year. It's nothing special.
啊，她们去年刚赢过。没什么特别的。
I like how every time I ask, you're like, nah, I don't care.
我喜欢你每次问我时，你都说，不，我不在乎。
No, it's not that I don't care, but they just won once. That was the first time they've won in a really long time, 'cause I think the last time they won was, like, in the '90s or something like that. So it was a big deal for them. But other than that, they're not a rival.
不，不是我不在乎，但她们只赢了一次。那是她们很久以来第一次赢，因为我想她们上一次赢是在90年代左右。所以这对她们来说是一件大事。但除此之外，她们不是竞争对手。
You're, like, very politely [BLEEP] talking them.
你这简直是在客气地（脏话）评价她们。
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's nothing special.
是的。是的，是的，是的。没什么特别的。
Finally, everyone shows up, and they run through their song a few times in practice. And then, for real.
最后，大家都到了，她们练习了几遍歌曲。然后，正式开始了。
Ladies and gentlemen, on stage, we have band number two. They are the Radoes.
女士们、先生们，在舞台上，我们有2号乐队。她们是Radoes。
They roll up on stage. There's about 100 of them. They've built out a float that looks like a tin spaceship, kind of. It's even hard to tell it's a spaceship, but Angie says it is.
她们走上舞台。大约有100人。她们搭建了一个看起来像锡制宇宙飞船的花车。甚至很难看出那是宇宙飞船，但安吉说是。
I have to say, to me, standing in the front few rows of the audience with my untrained ears, they sound a little rushed and messy. It's honestly hard to tell. As they play more, though, they get a little more sure-footed.
我不得不说，对我而言，站在前几排，听着我那未经训练的耳朵，她们听起来有点匆忙和混乱。说实话很难说。不过随着她们演奏得越来越多，她们变得越来越稳健了。
It takes nearly an hour to get each band on and off the stage. When Despers comes on, hours later, they look like professionals, definitely more polished. Their bandleader has this confidence and a little bravado, as if they've already won.
每支乐队上下台需要近一个小时。当几个小时后Despers上台时，她们看起来像专业人士，绝对更老练。她们的指挥有种自信和一点虚张声势，仿佛她们已经赢了。
Angie's not feeling good about this. And as the night goes on, she goes through a kind of pre-emptive expedited grieving process. Here she is an hour later, depression.
安吉对此感觉不好。随着夜幕深沉，她经历了一种先发制人的加速悲伤过程。一个小时后，她陷入了抑郁。
My grandmother used to say kingdoms rise and fall all the time. And so, I wonder if the kingdom is falling. It's hard to know.
我祖母常说王国总是兴起又衰落。所以，我想知道王国是否正在衰落。很难知道。
And at around 11:00, when we're getting closer to the end, acceptance.
大约11点，当我们接近尾声时，接受了现实。
We're not going to win this time around, I can see that.
这次我们赢不了了，我能看出来。
You're like, we're not going to win?
你是说，我们赢不了？
No, I don't see that happening. I don't see that happening.
不，我不觉得会发生那种事。我不觉得会发生那种事。
The Radoes' reign could be over. Things change, people move on. Jona is about to move on. But people from different bands keep coming over to Angie to say hello. She honestly seems to know everybody here.
Radoes的统治可能结束了。事情在变，人们在前进。乔娜正要前进。但来自不同乐队的人不断过来和安吉打招呼。她老实说似乎认识这里的所有人。
It combats the anonymity of America. Like, America is just one big place that you could be lost in. And we come from small places, right? And this is, as you know West Indians say, a kind of catch ass place. People don't have the kind of luxury of time as they do in the Caribbean, but they figure out a way to be together. And this is just another way to figure out how to be together, how to be together the way we are.
它对抗了美国的匿名性。就像，美国只是一个你可以迷失其中的大地方。而我们来自小地方，对吧？正如你们西印度群岛人所说，这是一个让人筋疲力尽的地方。人们不像在加勒比海那样拥有奢侈的时间，但她们想出了一种在一起的方法。这只是另一种找出如何在一起的方法，如何像我们这样在一起。
How to be together the way we are. Angie says when she was little, she couldn't stand Labor Day Carnival. She'd get tired and want to go home. And her dad would always try and linger, stretch it out a little longer. Now she gets it. There's a homesickness, even in Angie's case, if it's for a place where she hasn't really lived.
如何像我们这样在一起。安吉说她小时候很讨厌劳动节嘉年华。她会感到疲倦，想回家。她父亲总是想逗留，多待一会儿。现在她明白了。有一种思乡之情，即使在安吉的情况下，即使是对她并没有真正居住过的地方。
Is the president here? Please come on stage for the results.
主席到了吗？请上台宣布结果。
Duh duh duh.
嘟嘟嘟。
It's now past midnight, or 1:00 AM. Honestly, I don't remember. But it's the moment they've been waiting for. They're about to announce the winners. Everyone gathers closer and closer to the stage. The announcer starts with the last place band.
现在已经过了午夜，或凌晨1点。说实话，我不记得了。但这是她们一直在等待的时刻。她们即将宣布获胜者。每个人都越来越靠近舞台。播音员从最后一名乐队开始宣布。
Placing eighth, we have Harmony. Placing seventh, Cross Fire.
第八名，Harmony。第七名，Cross Fire。
This is all good news. It means Radoes hasn't lost yet. In sixth place, Philly Pan Stars. The crowd does not like that.
这都是好消息。这意味着Radoes还没输。第六名，Philly Pan Stars。人群不喜欢这个结果。
So I'm just reading what it said, OK?
我只是在读上面写的内容，好吗？
Fifth place, Chasm. At this point, each time the announcer doesn't say Radoes, Angie lets out an involuntary scream.
第五名，Chasm。此时，每次播音员没提到Radoes，安吉就会发出不由自主的尖叫。
Fourth, Despers USA.
第四名，Despers USA。
Despers, their rival, took fourth.
Despers，她们的竞争对手，拿了第四。
Third, Pan Evolution.
第三名，Pan Evolution。
OK, so now my hands are shaking.
好吧，现在我的手在发抖。
Placing second with a score of 458 and the winner, 459, placing second, Adlib.
以458分获得第二名，获胜者，459分，第二名是Adlib。
So that's it. Radoes won by a single point, 459 to 458.
就是这样。Radoes以一分之差获胜，459对458。
The Radoes.
Radoes。
I got to go. Come.
我得走了。来。
Come, Angie says. She grabs my hand and drags me on stage. We are running up this ramp, tons of people pushing through. Someone loses a shoe, but keeps going. They're screaming, dancing-- tons of hugs. And in the middle of the stage, Angie sees her daughter, surrounded by her friends. In a few hours, she'll be on the plane to college in California.
来，安吉说。她抓住我的手把我拖上舞台。我们正跑上斜坡，成堆的人挤在一起。有人掉了一只鞋，但继续跑。她们尖叫着、跳舞——成堆的拥抱。在舞台中央，安吉看到了被朋友包围的女儿。再过几个小时，她就要乘飞机去加利福尼亚上大学了。
I'm so overwhelmed.
我太不知所措了。
I don't want you to leave.
我不希望你离开。
'Cause I'm going to leave, like, now. But then we also won.
因为我要走了，就像，现在。但我们也赢了。
The person saying, "I don't want you to leave," that's Jona's bestie from the pan yard, Z. Jona looks at her and starts to cry. She told me later that she's known Z since she was 10. That every year, days after Panorama's over, they keep going to the pan yard anyway and hanging out until it got too cold to do it. And so this moment, standing on stage looking at her friends, that was when it really hit her. This part of her life with her mom and these friends in this world, it's over.
说“我不希望你离开”的那个人，是乔娜在钢鼓场最好的朋友Z。乔娜看着她，开始哭泣。她后来告诉我，她从10岁起就认识Z了。每年全景比赛结束后几天，她们无论如何都会继续去钢鼓场，在那里闲逛，直到天气冷得无法进行。所以这一刻，站在台上看着她的朋友们，那是她真正感受到的时候。她与母亲的这段生活，以及在这个世界里的这些朋友，结束了。
[MUSIC - FARMER NAPPY, "HOOKIN MEH"]
（音乐 - 法默·纳皮，《Hookin Meh》）
Marlon Bishop produces podcasts for Futuro Media Group, which makes Latino USA. Nadia Reiman is one of the producers of our show.
马龙·毕晓普为制作《拉丁裔美国人》的Futuro Media Group制作播客。纳迪亚·雷曼是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - FARMER NAPPY, "HOOKIN MEH"]
（音乐 - 法默·纳皮，《Hookin Meh》）
Coming up, we're going to need a mop in aisle seven. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
稍后，我们需要七号走廊有一把拖把。节目继续进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Neil Drumming, sitting in for Ira Glass. Today's show, We Come From Small Places, stories from the West Indian American Day parade and the Labor Day Carnival in Brooklyn, New York City.
这是《美国生活》。我是尼尔·德拉明，代替艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是《我们来自小地方》，关于西印度群岛日游行和纽约布鲁克林劳动节嘉年华的故事。
The neighborhood that the parade goes through includes another group of people that are unapologetically themselves. That's the Hasidic Jews. On this day, you'll see many of them dressed up in a costume that's particular to their culture. But unlike the mas players, they wear their uncolorful costumes year round-- the long black coats and black hats and beards, outfits that date back to 19th century Poland.
游行经过的街区还包括另一群毫无歉意地做自己的人。那就是哈西德派犹太人。在这一天，你会看到他们中的许多人穿着他们文化特有的服装。但与“玩假面”的人不同，他们全年都穿着不鲜艳的服装——长黑大衣、黑帽子和胡须，这可以追溯到19世纪的波兰。
During the parade, they all seem to be rushing down the street, like people on their way to an important appointment, not looking at the festivities at all. My co-worker, Ira Glass, the regular host of this program, was at the parade with us and tried to talk to some Hasids about this huge yearly event that takes place in their neighborhood.
在游行期间，他们似乎都在街上匆匆忙忙，就像要去参加重要约会的人，根本不看庆典。我的同事，本节目的常驻主持人艾拉·格拉斯，和我们一起参加了游行，并试图与一些哈西德派谈谈在他们街区举行的这场盛大的年度活动。
Walking up to Hasids on the street felt like walking up to people from another planet, people who had a general air of hostility-- or at least, suspicion-- towards outsiders like me. They waved me off. The best I got was from a young man who took pity on me and gamely mustered this non-committal quote about the parade.
在街上走近哈西德派就像走近来自另一个星球的人，他们对像我这样的外人有一种普遍的敌意——或者至少是怀疑。他们挥手让我离开。我得到的最好回应来自一个年轻人，他同情我，大方地挤出了这句关于游行的非承诺性引语。
Every person has a right to do what they want, what they feel is right.
每个人都有权做他们想做的事，做他们觉得正确的事。
But I finally found one Hasid who would actually talk to me by marching myself over to 770 Eastern Parkway, the worldwide headquarters of the Chabad movement. Chabad is the biggest Hasid organization.
但我终于找到了一个愿意真正与我交谈的哈西德人，通过径直走到东公园大道770号，也就是哈巴德运动的全球总部。哈巴德是最大的哈西德组织。
And 770 is such an important spiritual site for them that a replica of the building at 770 Eastern Parkway was built in Jerusalem, nearly a brick-by-brick copy, with other replicas in cities around the world, which include the number 770 on the building. The number has mystical significance, meaning, among other things, depending on who you ask, Beis Moshiach, House of the Messiah.
770对他们来说是一个如此重要的精神场所，以至于在耶路撒冷建造了东公园大道770号建筑的复制品，几乎是逐砖复制，世界各地的城市也有复制品，这些建筑上都包括数字770。这个数字具有神秘的意义，意味着，除其他事项外，取决于你问谁，贝斯·莫西亚赫（Beis Moshiach），即弥赛亚之家。
The 770 is not just a three digit number on the door and the address at 770 Eastern Parkway, Brooklyn, New York. It is the house of our leader, the leader of the entire human race.
770不仅仅是门上的三位数和纽约布鲁克林东公园大道770号的地址。它是我们领导人、全人类领导人的家。
Lubavitcher Rebbe.
卢巴维奇雷贝（Lubavitcher Rebbe）。
Right.
对。
The man telling me this is Yehuda Menasha Goldstein, a middle-aged fellow with a very kind face, long graying beard, wire-rimmed glasses. And he's talking about the last great leader of the Chabad movement, who died in 1994, has no successor, Menachem Mendel Schneerson. Some, like Yehuda, believe Schneerson was the messiah.
告诉我这一切的人是耶胡达·梅纳沙·戈尔茨坦，一个有着非常友善面孔的中年人，长长的灰色胡须，戴着金属框眼镜。他谈论的是哈巴德运动最后一位伟大的领导人，于1994年去世，没有继任者，梅纳赫姆·门德尔·施内尔森。有些人，像耶胡达，相信施内尔森就是弥赛亚。
Yehuda spoke with me because he's taken it upon himself to be a schliach, which is a kind of emissary or missionary spreading the word about God's laws. And what that meant was that when I strode up to 770, he seemed just as glad for somebody to talk to as I was. Like, he walked up to me. Like, God had sent us both out to talk to strangers on this day at the parade, and now, here we were.
耶胡达之所以跟我说话，是因为他自认为是“信使”（schliach），这是一种传教士，传播关于上帝律法的信息。这意味着当我大步走向770时，他似乎很高兴有人和他交谈，就像我一样。就像，他走向我。就像，上帝在那天派我们俩出来在游行中与陌生人交谈，现在，我们在这里了。
He admitted he'd put up a handmade sign across the parade route about the seven laws of Noah. And he was kind of hoping that the sign would do a lot of the proselytizing for him today, and he wouldn't have to engage too much with the crowd.
他承认他在游行路线上竖起了一个关于诺亚七律的手写标志。他有点希望这个标志能替他完成今天的传教工作，他就不必太多地与人群互动了。
Due to the weakness of the eyes, I try to put signs over there to do my work for me. Because if I see what's going on over here, it really triggers a lot of emotional prohibited thoughts that you have to really not let play out, get played enough to guard your eyes in this.
由于眼睛虚弱，我试着把标志放在那里替我工作。因为如果我看到这里发生了什么，这真的会引发许多情绪化的禁止思想，你真的必须不允许它们上演，让它们得到足够的发挥来保护你的眼睛。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
Well, the distracting, sexually explicit, beautiful women. They are very arousing and provocative.
嗯，那些分散注意力的、露骨的、美丽的女性。她们非常令人兴奋和挑衅。
Remember, we're standing on the street with literally hundreds of women in bikinis going by, lots of bare skin.
记住，我们正站在街上， literally数百名身穿比基尼的女性经过，露出大量皮肤。
So the women on top of that float going by, you're not supposed to even look at them?
所以那个花车上的女性经过时，你甚至不应该看她们？
I plead the fifth, man.
我行使第五修正案权利，伙计。
It didn't occur to me. I didn't realize, right, to have a parade like this right in the middle of the Hasid neighborhood, right here in front of 770-- it's a challenge.
我没想到。我没意识到，对吧，在哈西德社区中间举行这样的游行，就在770前面——这是一种挑战。
Right, and I had prayed about it last night. And I was 50/50 with God because that was full on winding it. And I was full on asking for help to overcome and not sin because I know my weaknesses. I'm very human. I'm very masculine. And when you see that very feminine, it's a little more than a challenge to. But when God is blessing you, God is with you, you can still manage to not sin.
对，而且我昨晚为此祈祷过。我和上帝之间是50/50，因为那是全身心地投入。我完全请求上帝帮助我克服不犯罪，因为我知道我的弱点。我非常人性化。我非常有阳刚之气。当你看到那种非常女性化的东西时，这不仅仅是一个挑战。但当上帝保佑你时，上帝与你同在，你仍然可以设法不犯罪。
What did you pray for?
你祈祷什么？
Prayed that God would prevent me from sinning.
祈祷上帝阻止我犯罪。
Prevent you from looking even.
阻止你甚至看？
Well, yeah. I have to admit that I asked that. But obviously, whatever. It's a fight. I mean, you seem to be quite uninterested to look yourself. You seem to be more interested in getting a story and talking and writing material for--
嗯，是的。我必须承认我问过那个。但显然，无论如何。这是一场斗争。我的意思是，你自己似乎很不感兴趣去看。你似乎更感兴趣获取故事，交谈和撰写材料……
I have a job I'm supposed to do, yeah.
我有一项工作要完成，是的。
Also, I'm a secular person who is allowed to look at women walking by in a parade. God wants us to be holy, Yehuda said. He wants us to elevate our souls. And really, he said, the right thing to do today would be to guard his eyes. He admitted for all his praying last night, today--
此外，我是一个世俗的人，被允许看在游行中经过的女性。上帝希望我们圣洁，耶胡达说。他希望我们提升我们的灵魂。真的，他说，今天正确的做法是守护他的眼睛。他承认，尽管昨晚祈祷了那么多，但今天……
A couple of times, I was looking a little too long at some nice shapes. Mentally, I have to work on that because it's not right. And I even pointed as they walked by. And then some people caught me pointing and said, oh, see that Jewish guy? He's even into the looking, and laughing at me. Look at that guy. Look at that rabbi. He's copping a look. Yeah, well, I admit it. Well, Yom Kippur is coming in 40 days.
有好几次，我盯着一些漂亮的形状看了太久。在精神上，我必须处理这个问题，因为这是不对的。当她们经过时，我甚至指了一下。然后有些人抓住我指点，说，哦，看到那个犹太人了？他甚至也盯着看，嘲笑我。看那个家伙。看那个拉比。他在偷窥。是的，好吧，我承认。好吧，赎罪日（Yom Kippur）还有40天就到了。
Yom Kippur, the Day of Atonement, when once a year, through repentance, prayer, and charity, Jews get their chance to make things right again with God, for the moments we strayed.
赎罪日，是一年一度的弥补日，通过忏悔、祈祷和慈善，犹太人有机会再次与上帝达成和解，为了我们走偏的时刻。
Two blocks west of 770, a block south of the parade route on Union Street, I spot two Hasidic boys in front of their apartment building with a cooler and handmade signs that read "Cookies for Sale" and "Ice Pops for Sale."
在770以西两个街区，联合街游行路线以南一个街区，我发现两个哈西德男孩在他们的公寓楼前，带着一个冷藏箱和手写标志，上面写着“饼干出售”和“冰棒出售”。
And so how much are they?
那它们多少钱？
They're $0.15 each.
每个0.15美元。
Have you sold many?
你卖了很多吗？
Yeah.
是的。
How many have you sold?
你卖了多少？
Two.
两个。
How long have you been here?
你在这里待了多久？
A half hour.
半小时。
OK, that's pretty good, so $0.30. What's your name?
好的，那还不错，所以0.30美元。你叫什么名字？
I don't want to say.
我不想说。
Can I say my name?
我可以报我的名字吗？
Ah, little brothers, clueless. This one's seven, the other guy's 12. The little one proceeds to tell me his name, which, later, his older brother asked me not to put on the radio. They're used to the parade. It's every year.
啊，小兄弟们，一无所知。这个7岁，另一个12岁。小的开始告诉我他的名字，后来他的哥哥要求我不要在电台播放。他们习惯了游行。每年都有。
They woke me up at 3:00 AM in the morning.
他们凌晨3点把我吵醒了。
There was a bunch of people with symbols and then just marching down that block.
有一群带着符号的人，然后就这样列队走过那个街区。
Do you like that this kind of thing happens in the neighborhood?
你喜欢社区发生这种事吗？
No.
不喜欢。
Your brother is shaking your head no. You don't like it.
你哥哥在摇头说不。你不喜欢。
No.
不喜欢。
How come?
为什么？
Because it's very noisy and dangerous.
因为它很吵，而且危险。
What's the dangerous part?
危险的部分是什么？
People are walking around crazy.
人们在周围走动得很疯狂。
Have you seen anything crazy?
你看到什么疯狂的事了吗？
Yes.
是的。
They described to me some people yelling, threatening each other a couple of doors down from them about an hour before this. I asked for another example.
他们向我描述了一些人在离他们几个门的地方大喊大叫，互相威胁，大约在一小时前。我要求另一个例子。
People are walking around with knives and guns.
人们带着刀和枪在走动。
Wait, have you seen knives and guns? You're just here.
等等，你看到刀和枪了吗？你只是待在这里。
Yes. Wait, hold on, I don't want to say it on there. Do you want me to say what I have in my pocket?
是的。等等，等一下，我不想在上面说。你想让我说我口袋里有什么吗？
His older brother explains it's just because he's scared.
他的哥哥解释说这只是因为他害怕。
What does he have in his pocket?
他口袋里有什么？
Scissors.
剪刀。
You have scissors in your pocket because you're scared?
你口袋里有剪刀是因为你害怕？
I had scissors in my pocket just in case anything happens.
我口袋里带着剪刀以防万一。
He fetches them and shows me. To be clear, these scissors are kid scissors, like safety scissors like you use in second grade.
他拿出来给我看。清楚地说，这些剪刀是儿童剪刀，就像二年级用的安全剪刀。
What were you going to do with the scissors?
你打算用剪刀做什么？
If someone were to come with a knife, I would tell them look over there, and grab the knife, and then stab them.
如果有人带刀来，我会告诉他们看那边，然后抓住刀，然后刺他们。
Your brother's laughing. You don't think that plan would work.
你哥哥在笑。你不觉得那个计划行得通。
No, it wouldn't.
不，行不通。
I think it would work.
我觉得行得通。
We start discussing how scary the parade seems to them and the people in the parade when a bunch of women amble up to us.
当我们讨论游行对他们来说有多可怕时，一群女性慢悠悠地向我们走来。
Hi.
嗨。
Hey, guys.
嘿，伙计们。
Hi.
嗨。
This is our old building.
这是我们的旧建筑。
We want to take a picture right here.
我们要在这里拍张照。
So we needed to take a picture here.
所以我们需要在这里拍张照。
We lived here 20 years ago.
我们20年前住在这里。
Yeah, that's my old room right there. So we're just going to do a picture because we were here. This was my old room.
是的，那就是我以前的房间。所以我们只是要拍张照，因为我们来过这里。这是我以前的房间。
I tell the women that these boys live in the building.
我告诉这些女士这些男孩住在这栋楼里。
Well, maybe these guys live in your apartment.
嗯，也许这些人住在你的公寓里。
I don't know. What apartment do you guys live in?
我不知道。你们住在哪个公寓？
We're on that side.
我们在那边。
No, we lived on that side. But we always take an annual picture, and we just need to do that. So I hope you don't mind.
不，我们住在那边。但我们总是拍年度照片，我们只需要做那个。所以我希望你不介意。
So you guys used to live in the neighborhood.
所以你们以前住在这个街区。
Yeah.
是的。
Where did you move to?
你们搬到哪儿了？
All over.
到处都是。
All over. And then you come back every year for the parade?
到处都是。然后你们每年都回来参加游行？
Yeah. And then we take a photo shoot here.
是的。然后我们在这里拍照片。
They line up in front of the door with the building number above it. The friend frames the shot in her phone.
她们排在门口，上方有楼号。朋友在手机上构图。
Say Guyana.
说圭亚那。
Guyana.
圭亚那。
Ah.
啊。
They do a Boomerang.
她们拍了一个回旋镖视频。
What's a Boomerang?
什么是回旋镖？
And then the important business finished, they chat. They explain to me that their names are Denille and Charlene.
然后重要的事情完成了，她们聊天。她们向我解释她们的名字叫丹妮尔和查琳。
Perfect. Yeah, this is our old block.
太完美了。是的，这是我们的旧街区。
That's so sweet. Has it changed much?
太甜了。它改变了很多吗？
Well, with the new neighbors, yeah. But there's still people across the street that still have the same house. My room used to be right there-- Mommy's room, Keisha's room, my room, the living room. This is a great building. It's only seven apartments in this apartment building, and they're so huge--
嗯，有了新邻居，是的。但街对面还是有人住在同一栋房子里。我的房间过去就在那里——妈咪的房间，基莎的房间，我的房间，客厅。这是一栋很棒的建筑。这栋公寓楼只有七套公寓，它们太大了——
That's nice. That's nice.
那很好。那很好。
--at $350 a month. Can you remember?
——每个月350美元。记得吗？
It was the '90s.
那是90年代。
She turns to the 12- and 7-year-old-- they're sitting there, stone silent-- and talks to the little one.
她转向12岁和7岁的孩子——她们坐在那里，石头般沉默——并对小的那个说话。
Matter of fact, my little sister, matter of fact, was your age. And she's like 40 something now, and I'm 50.
事实上，我小妹妹，事实上，和你一般大。她现在40多岁了，我50岁了。
And then were there Hasids in the neighborhood on the block back then?
那时候街区里有哈西德人吗？
We used to live in the building with them. We have no problem with the Orthodox Jews, never. We played with them. There was great houses down there. We were friends with them. Never a problem. Never ever, ever, ever, ever, ever, ever a problem with the Orthodox ever.
我们以前和他们住在一栋楼里。我们和正统犹太人没问题，从来没有。我们和他们一起玩。那边有很棒的房子。我们和他们是朋友。从来没有问题。从来，从来，从来，从来，从来，从来，从来没有和正统犹太人有过问题。
They stroll off. The 12-year-old tells me that one of them slipped him a dollar when I wasn't watching. Biggest sale of the day. Those ladies, so nice. New Yorkers can be so friendly. I know that's not the stereotype of New Yorkers, but I find often the case. Little brother didn't even have to pull out his scissors.
她们溜达走了。12岁的孩子告诉我，其中一个在我没注意的时候塞给他一美元。当天最大的销售额。那些女士，太好了。纽约人可以非常友好。我知道这不是纽约人的刻板印象，但我发现通常情况如此。弟弟甚至不需要拿出他的剪刀。
Ira Glass.
艾拉·格拉斯。
So the parade, it involves an incredible number of feathers. And there's this kind of funny thing that I learned. A lot of them come from this one shop on West 37th Street in the Garment District. So I want to leave Eastern Parkway for a minute and take you there. We visited a couple of weeks before the parade. It's like a candy store inside, except the bins that line the walls are filled with different colors of feathers, sequins, and rhinestones.
所以游行涉及难以置信数量的羽毛。我学到了一件有趣的事情。它们很多来自西37街服装区的一家商店。所以我想离开东公园大道一分钟，带你去那里。我们在游行前几周访问了那里。里面就像糖果店，除了墙上的箱子装满了不同颜色的羽毛、亮片和水钻。
The owner is not from the West Indies. He's never been to Brooklyn Carnival. His name's Hai, and he's originally from China. And he showed my co-producer Jessica some of this year's costumes, including an outfit with about 1,000 rhinestones sewn into it.
店主不是来自西印度群岛。他从未去过布鲁克林狂欢节。他叫海（Hai），最初来自中国。他向我的联合制片人杰西卡展示了今年的服装，包括一件缝了大约1000颗水钻的服装。
I don't know. Is that clear or white or what--
我不知道。是透明的还是白的还是什么……
AB.
AB（极光色）。
AB, what does that mean?
AB，那是什么意思？
Aurora Borealis color. These are all AB color stones.
北极光颜色。这些都是AB颜色的石头。
What does that mean? What does--
那是什么意思？那是什么……
It color changes based on the light. There's a lot of colors in it.
它根据光线改变颜色。里面有很多颜色。
When Hai first opened his shop, his main customers were figure skaters, ballroom dancers, and drag queens. He'd never heard of Carnival. Then about 12 years ago, a Trinidadian man walked into his shop and asked for 400 identical sequined appliques. It turns out the guy was buying them for Carnival for one of the big costume groups you see march in the parade. They're called mas bands, or mas camps. Again, the mas is for masquerade.
当海第一次开店时，他的主要客户是花样滑冰运动员、舞厅舞者和变装皇后。他从未听说过狂欢节。然后大约12年前，一个特立尼达男人走进他的店，要求要400个相同的亮片贴花。原来那家伙是在为狂欢节购买它们，为了你在游行中看到的游行队伍之一。它们被称为“假面乐队”（mas bands）或“假面营”（mas camps）。再一次，mas是为假面舞会。
Now Hai is the go-to guy for Carnival feathers for so many bands, not just here, but all over the Caribbean. Everyone knows Hai, one Trinidadian told us. While Jessica was in Hai's shop, the leader of one of the biggest mas camps in Brooklyn stopped by. Her name is Reishelle Maynard-Richards. She runs a camp called Ramajay.
现在海是这么多乐队的狂欢节羽毛首选商，不仅在这里，而且在整个加勒比地区。每个人都知道海，一个特立尼达人告诉我们。当杰西卡在海的店里时，布鲁克林最大的假面营之一的领导人顺道拜访。她的名字叫雷谢尔·梅纳德-理查兹。她经营着一个叫Ramajay的营地。
And half will be leg pieces, arm pieces. Ramajay.
一半是腿部部件，手臂部件。Ramajay。
How are you?
你好吗？
Yeah, your stuff is here. Wow, you guys are so lucky.
是的，你的东西在这儿。哇，你们太幸运了。
Hi.
嗨。
Hello.
你好。
How are you?
你好吗？
That's the Ramajay bandleader. Yeah, sure. They accept us.
那是Ramajay的队长。是的，当然。她们接受我们。
Oh, this is pretty.
哦，这个很漂亮。
Yeah, right?
是的，对吧？
It is pretty.
它很漂亮。
Hai is pulling bra tops out of big boxes and showing Reishelle.
海正在把胸罩从大盒子里拿出来展示给雷谢尔看。
What color is that? Like, sherbet or what would you call that?
那个颜色是什么？像冰沙还是你会怎么称呼它？
Coral.
珊瑚色。
Coral or shrimp color.
珊瑚色或虾色。
I came to get the feathers for today. Are you getting the feathers for that one today?
我是来拿今天的羽毛的。你今天在拿那件的羽毛吗？
All these are your feathers, no?
所有这些都是你的羽毛，不是吗？
Yes.
是的。
All these are your feathers.
所有这些都是你的羽毛。
Reishelle went off to pick out more ostrich plumes, which are some of the most expensive feathers in the shop. It turns out that all these feathers are real. Hai gets his ostrich plumes from farms in South Africa. The turkey feathers, mostly from Missouri. And there are also these really long, striped pheasant tail feathers. Those are from farms in Vietnam and Cambodia. Each individual feather or piece costs $25.
雷谢尔去挑选更多的鸵鸟毛，这是店里最昂贵的羽毛。原来所有这些羽毛都是真的。海从南非的农场获得鸵鸟毛。火鸡毛，主要来自密苏里州。还有这些非常长的、有条纹的雉尾羽。那些来自越南和柬埔寨的农场。每一根羽毛或碎片花费25美元。
And sometimes you'll see individual masqueraders having over 200 pieces on their backpack, and just imagine how much money he spent on that one backpack.
有时你会看到参与假面游行的人在背包上有200多件碎片，想象一下他在那个背包上花了多少钱。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah, but those are very Carnival and this is what they love. And so they save up for that one costume, right?
是的，但这些非常狂欢节，这就是她们所爱的。所以她们为那件服装攒钱，对吧？
When the actual finished product walks down the Parkway, you're looking at almost a year's worth of work by everyone from peacock farmers in Cambodia to the designers in Trinidad and the seamstresses in southern China to Reishelle and her family in Canarsie, where her father actually hand glues feathers onto wire and bends them into headdresses and wings.
当最终成品走过大道时，你看到的是从柬埔寨的孔雀农场到特立尼达的设计师，再到中国南方的女裁缝，最后到雷谢尔和她在卡纳西的家人——她父亲在那里实际上用手工将羽毛粘在铁丝上，并弯曲成头饰和翅膀——所有人近一年的工作。
One other important thing that you should know about Hai's feathers is that people tell us that, because they're real, they're waterproof. Which is fortunate, because this year, it started pouring down rain early Labor Day morning. And Jessica and I found maybe 100 masqueraders hiding out in a nearby Walgreens. In the cosmetics aisle, I saw a woman posing for a picture like some odd winged supermodel underneath the fluorescent lights.
关于海的羽毛，你还应该知道另一件重要的事情是，人们告诉我们，因为它们是真的，所以它们是防水的。这很幸运，因为今年，劳动节清晨开始下雨。我和杰西卡发现可能有100名参与者躲在附近的Walgreens店里。在化妆品区，我看到一个女人像某种奇怪的带翼超模一样在荧光灯下摆姿势拍照。
There was a long line to the bathroom, women in sequined bikinis crowding in two at a time. Even though everyone's feathers were soaked through and drooping, they were trying to stay in good spirits.
去洗手间的队伍很长，穿着亮片比基尼的女性每次挤进两个人。尽管每个人的羽毛都湿透了并下垂，但她们仍在努力保持良好的精神状态。
It ain't going to stop. And we're drying our feathers.
它不会停。我们正在晾干我们的羽毛。
I took my feathers off to dry.
我脱下羽毛晾干。
It's wet. They are hanging up behind me in a bunch of school supplies. Yeah, I don't know. I guess, I'm curious, like, does the fact that it's raining, like--
它湿了。它们挂在我身后的办公用品堆里。是的，我不知道。我想，我很好奇，雨会不会……
No, it don't stop us.
不，它阻止不了我们。
It don't stop us. We could party in the rain.
它阻止不了我们。我们可以在雨中派对。
It don't stop us, and the party don't stop.
它阻止不了我们，派对也不会停止。
I'm still running the Parkway.
我还在走大道。
It's our culture. We're here to pick up our culture, you know what I mean? Like, rain or shine, tornado.
这是我们的文化。我们来这里是为了拾起我们的文化，你知道我的意思吗？就像，风雨无阻，龙卷风。
Eventually the rain stopped. People put on their damp costumes and rejoined the parade. Mas players pay hundreds of dollars to join mas bands. For their money, the masqueraders get a costume, food and drink, and a chance to dance behind a truck with an obscenely loud sound system.
最终雨停了。人们穿上潮湿的服装重新加入了游行。参与者付几百美元加入假面乐队。为了钱，参与者得到一套服装、食物和饮料，以及在声音大得离谱的音响系统后面跳舞的机会。
The folks at Ramajay, they say the number of masqueraders has been dropping over the years. This is Darryl Cox. He designs costumes for Ramajay. He was wearing a jewel-encrusted ski mask at the time.
Ramajay的人说，参与者的数量多年来一直在下降。这是达里尔·考克斯。他为Ramajay设计服装。他当时戴着一个镶满珠宝的滑雪面罩。
So there's a whole bunch of factors that play into part. But overall, I think it's just people may want to do different things with their income. They may not necessarily want to be half naked on the road for a couple hours, so.
所以有很多因素在起作用。但总的来说，我认为人们可能想用他们的收入做不同的事情。他们未必想在那路上半裸几个小时，所以。
What Darryl means is they'd prefer to be half naked on the road for considerably more than a few hours. He says the mas play business is suffering because people feel like the city is getting more and more strict every year about when the parade is supposed to end. Everyone's supposed to be off the road by 6:00, so masqueraders are less inclined to pay a band like Ramajay for the experience.
达里尔的意思是，他们更愿意在路上半裸超过几个小时。他说假面游行生意受到打击，因为人们觉得城市每年都越来越严格，关于游行应该在什么时候结束。每个人都应该在6点前离开公路，所以参与者就不太倾向于向Ramajay这样的乐队付钱体验。
And one of our biggest battles is why should I spend $600 for a costume in New York when I can spend that on a flight and go to St. Lucia, or go to Jamaica, or go somewhere else and play mas there?
我们最大的战斗之一是，为什么当我可以花那笔钱买机票去圣卢西亚，或者去牙买加，或者去其他地方并在那里玩假面时，我要在纽约花600美元买一套服装？
That's Reishelle, the woman we met in the feather shop on 37. She founded Ramajay about a decade ago and turned it into the family business. Her father played mas in Trinidad, and to this day, still spends months helping her make the band's lavish costumes by hand. For Reishelle, these days, not enough people are willing to commit to the masquerade, to the tradition of playing mas.
那是我们在37街羽毛店遇到的女人雷谢尔。她大约十年前创立了Ramajay并将其变成了家族生意。她父亲在特立尼达玩过假面，至今仍花几个月时间帮她手工制作乐队奢华的服装。对雷谢尔来说，这些天来，没有足够多的人愿意致力于化装舞会，致力于玩假面的传统。
When you walk, what you see now, you don't see much costumes anymore. You see a lot of T-shirts and just flags. A lot of people don't get to witness the beauty of the costumes anymore, because they just see flags, and rags, and short pants, and they don't see the beauty of a lot of the costumes anymore.
当你走的时候，你现在看到的，你看不见太多服装了。你看到很多T恤和旗帜。很多人不再目睹服装的美了，因为她们只看到旗帜、破布和短裤，她们不再看到许多服装的美。
Within Caribbean culture, not everyone is steeped in the same traditions Reishelle was taught. They celebrate however they can. Though there's one way of cutting loose that seems to be happening more and more, and it drives Reishelle and her staff crazy. When Ramajay rolls down the Parkway, speakers blasting, some bystanders hop the metal barriers and flood the band's ranks, dancing and waving their flags. People call this storming. Some mas players welcome it, like the more, the merrier.
在加勒比文化中，并非每个人都沉浸在雷谢尔所教的相同传统中。她们尽可能地庆祝。虽然有一种放松的方式似乎越来越多，这让雷谢尔和她的员工发疯。当Ramajay在大道上滚动，音箱轰鸣时，一些旁观者越过金属护栏，淹没了乐队的行列，跳舞和挥舞旗帜。人们称之为“风暴”。一些参与者欢迎它，比如多多益善。
But it doesn't look great. The traditional mas players in their feathers and jewels, jostled and crowded by stormers in shorts and T-shirts and everyday street clothes, it's just messy. And it can also be dangerous. People get harassed, even assaulted. Fights can break out. The DJs kept trying to separate the non-paying civilians from the costumed players.
但这看起来不太好。身着羽毛和珠宝的传统参与者，被穿着短裤、T恤和日常街头服装的参与者推搡和拥挤，这只是混乱。而且它也可能是危险的。人们受到骚扰，甚至遭到攻击。争吵会爆发。DJ们一直试图将不付钱的平民与穿着服装的参与者分开。
But make way for the masqueraders, please. We ask that all the people who are not playing mas to step to the right side, far, far right side of the truck, please, and make space for the masqueraders. And ladies and the men, stop winding with the outsiders and encouraging these things now. Stop winding on the outsiders, OK?
但请为参与者让路。我们要求所有不玩假面的人站在右侧，卡车的远右侧，请，为参与者腾出空间。女士和先生们，停止和外人扭动并鼓励这些事情。停止和外人扭动，好吗？
They made this announcement over and over, without much impact. And the band security got pretty fed up trying to enforce it.
他们反复宣布这个，没有多大影响。乐队保安为了强迫执行而非常受够了。
I need the costumes to come through. Anybody that have on costumes, come through. Costumes, come through. Anybody without costumes, you're not coming in. I don't give a [BLEEP] what y'all say. Y'all mother [BLEEP] ain't coming in.
我需要服装通过。任何穿着服装的人，通过。服装，通过。任何没有服装的人，你们不能进来。我不在乎你们说什么。你们他妈的不能进来。
Reishelle has had enough. She recently decided that this would be Ramajay's last year in playing mas in New York City. And the stormers are why she's calling it quits. Ramajay will continue to play mas, but Reishelle would rather fly her staff to Miami, where she feels more people embrace Carnival as she knows it. It's big news. Again, here's Darryl, Ramajay's designer.
雷谢尔受够了。她最近决定这将是Ramajay在纽约市玩假面的最后一年。而这些“风暴者”就是她要退出原因。Ramajay将继续玩假面，但雷谢尔宁愿把她的员工带到迈阿密，在那里她觉得更多人接受她所知道的狂欢节。这是大新闻。再次，这是Ramajay的设计师达里尔。
There's a lot of sadness. I haven't really even been dancing because it's almost like I miss this, but I don't miss it. Everyone seems to be happy. And I think it's finally going to hit them when we cross that stage one last time. That's not going to happen again.
有很多悲伤。我甚至还没有真正跳舞，因为它几乎就像我错过了这个，但我并没有错过。每个人似乎都很开心。我想当我们要最后一次越过那个舞台时，它最终会击中她们。那是不会再发生的了。
It's easy to think of a parade as something unchanging, something that passes through the same place at the same time every year. The Carnival is this living thing that goes anywhere it's welcome, picking up pieces here and there, and dropping them off along the way.
很容易认为游行是不变的东西，每年在同一时间经过同一个地方的东西。狂欢节是一个活着的东西，它去任何受欢迎的地方，在这里或那里拾起碎片，并沿途放下它们。
Just as Ramajay is reaching the end of the parade route, the sky cracks open again, drenching the procession in steady sheets of rain. Plenty of people flee through the barriers for the safety of open subway entrances or storefront awnings. But a lot of people stay. And then something kind of magical happens. Ramajay's DJs crank up the music. They lead the mas bands and chants of wetted up, and the people want water, almost as if they were taunting the clouds, daring the rain to fall.
就在Ramajay到达游行路线终点时，天空再次裂开，将游行队伍浸泡在稳定的雨帘中。许多人通过护栏逃向开放的地铁入口或店面遮阳篷的安全地带。但很多人留下了。然后发生了某种魔法般的事情。Ramajay的DJ调高了音乐。他们带领假面乐队高呼着被淋湿了，人们想要水，几乎好像他们在嘲弄云朵，敢雨下下来。
The masqueraders, already soggy from earlier, collectively decide, what the hell, and start to jump up in unison, harder and more exuberantly than they have all day. As they cross the finish line, the band is as presentable as it can be under the circumstances. And it's just like Darryl predicted. There's lots of people crying-- Reishelle, her family, her security, and the people who have been playing mas with Ramajay for years.
参与者，已经在早些时候湿透了，集体决定，管他呢，开始同步跳跃，比他们一整天都跳得更用力、更充沛。当她们越过终点线时，乐队在那种情况下表现得尽可能得体。就像达里尔预测的那样。有很多哭泣的人——雷谢尔、她的家人、她的保安，以及多年来与Ramajay一起玩假面的人。
They pass by a panel of judges who are supposed to be scoring them on presentation. But honestly, the judging seems like it's beside the point right now. Everyone just seems happy to have spent all this time together, and they just want to keep winding and rocking.
她们经过一组评委，评委本应根据表现给她们打分。但老实说，评判似乎现在不是重点。每个人似乎只是很高兴在一起花了这么多时间，她们只想继续扭动和摇摆。
How many people need two more hours on the road? Put your hands up in the sky right now.
多少人还需要在路上多待两个小时？现在把你们的手举向天空。
Our show was produced today by myself and Jessica Lussenhop. The people who worked on the show include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Emanuele Berry, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Hilary Elkins, Ira Glass, Damian Grave, Michelle Harris, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Catherine Raimondo, Nadia Reiman, Tracy Rowland, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Our managing editor is Diane Wu. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum.
我们的节目今天由我和杰西卡·勒森霍普制作。制作节目的还有Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Emanuele Berry, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Hilary Elkins, Ira Glass, Damian Grave, Michelle Harris, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Catherine Raimondo, Nadia Reiman, Tracy Rowland, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, 和 Nancy Updike。我们的总编辑是Diane Wu。我们的执行编辑是David Kestenbaum。
Special thanks today to the West Indian American Day Carnival Association for providing audio of the steel pan competition. Also to Evon Asforis, Hannah Giorgis, Lynette Joseph Brown, Aaron Edwards, Doreen St. Félix, Gabrielle A. Smith, Nico Osborne, Angela Howard, Jona Inniss, Junior "Man" Samuel, Tom Montvel-Cohen, and the rest of the D'Radoes Steel Orchestra, Garth Green, Stacy Gardiner from Stronjeh International, Kenneth Antoine of Antoine International, and Staceyann Chin.
今天特别感谢西印度裔美国人狂欢节协会提供钢鼓比赛的音频。也感谢Evon Asforis, Hannah Giorgis, Lynette Joseph Brown, Aaron Edwards, Doreen St. Félix, Gabrielle A. Smith, Nico Osborne, Angela Howard, Jona Inniss, Junior "Man" Samuel, Tom Montvel-Cohen，以及D'Radoes钢鼓乐团的其他成员，Garth Green, Stacy Gardiner（来自Stronjeh International），Kenneth Antoine（来自Antoine International），和Staceyann Chin。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our show's host, Ira Glass. The last time Ira and I went out for KFC, he got heartburn like I'd never seen. I felt really bad.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的主持人艾拉·格拉斯。上次艾拉和我出去吃肯德基时，他得了我从未见过的胃灼热。我感觉真的很糟糕。
Me and a two-piece, we ain't friends right now.
我和两件套比基尼现在合不来。
I'm Neil Drumming. Ira Glass will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是尼尔·德拉明。艾拉·格拉斯下周将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。